So we built a virus-resistant organism.
Why?
It's not about disease, or not directly.
It's about building
the clean factories of the future.
Let me explain by taking a big step back.
All life runs on DNA.
DNA codes for proteins,
and proteins run life.
DNA is composed of four bases:
A, T, G and C.
And triplets of these bases,
known as codons,
encode each of the amino acid
building blocks in proteins.
The genetic code is a rulebook
that defines which codon
encodes which amino acid.
So, for example,
the triplet codon TCG
encodes the amino acid serine.
And the order of triplet codons in DNA
encodes the order of amino acid
building blocks in a protein.
There are 64 triplet codons in DNA
and just 20 common amino acids.
And this means that most amino acids
are encoded by more than
one triplet codon.
So, for example, the amino acid serine
is encoded by six different
triplet codons.
And triplet codons
that encode the same amino acid
are defined as synonymous codons.
The DNA code used for life
is near universal.
All forms of life and viruses
use essentially the same genetic code.
And that's a trait that we can exploit.
Here's what we did.
We asked whether life needs
multiple synonymous codons
to encode a single amino acid.
For example, does life need
six different codons,
which all code for the amino acid serine?
We took the four-million-character
DNA of E. coli, its genome,
and completely rewrote
the code of this microbe
in a very specific way
by replacing targeted codons in its genome
with synonymous codons
that encode the same amino acid.
So for example,
we replaced the TCG and TCA codons,
which encode the amino acid serine,
with AGT and AGC codons,
which also encode the amino acid serine.
By doing this across the whole
four-million-base genome,
we completely removed the targeted codons
from the genetic code of E. coli.
Overall, we compressed the genetic code
from using 64 codons to using 61 codons.
How did we do it?
We first took the four-million-character
code in a computer
and used a find-and-replace operation
to replace targeted codons
with their synonyms.
This created our new genome design,
which contained more than 18,000 changes
with respect to the original genome.
We then asked whether
we could build an organism
that runs on our synthetic genome design.
We built the synthetic genome
starting from short pieces of DNA.
These were made by chemistry
in a test tube,
something that would have been
prohibitively expensive to do
on this scale just a decade or two ago.
We then assembled
these short pieces of DNA
into longer stretches of DNA,
which we then used to step-by-step replace
all four million bases
of the E. coli genome.
This created the largest
synthetic genome ever made.
And the resulting cell was alive.
Think about that.
We streamlined the genetic code,
and yet the cell lived.
We can create life
with a compressed genetic code.
Now because our organism
with a compressed genetic code
doesn't use all 64 triplet codons
to make proteins,
we could remove some
of the machinery from the cell
that normally reads
the near-universal genetic code.
Specifically, we could remove components
of the translational machinery,
specific tRNAs,
that normally read the codons
that we've removed from the genome.
Now, the key point here
is that we've created a cell
that no longer reads all the codons
in the near-universal genetic code.
Now viruses infect cells.
These might be the cells of our bodies
or single-celled microbes like E.coli.
They commonly have their own DNA,
which uses the near-universal genetic code
to encode the proteins necessary
to make copies of the virus.
But viruses don't have the machinery
to read the genetic code in their DNA,
and instead they rely on the host cell,
the machinery of the host cell,
to read the genetic code in their DNA
and make copies of the virus.
It's these copies of the virus
that go on to infect other cells.
And this is how viruses spread.
But viruses are unable to make copies
of themselves in our new organism
because our new organism
doesn't have the machinery
to read all the codons
in the DNA of the virus.
The code in the DNA used in the virus
and the host cell's machinery
to read that code are incompatible.
Therefore, the virus doesn’t spread
in the new organism,
and the new organism
is resistant to viruses.
In fact, we showed that our new organism
was resistant to a wide range of viruses,
suggesting that rewriting the genetic code
provides a route to creating
broadly virus-resistant life.
By extending the approaches
we've developed to other organisms,
it may be possible to create
virus-resistant crops and animals
with important applications
in agriculture and beyond.
But our advances also provide a foundation
for turning cells into
the clean factories of the future.
How?
So to explain,
let me take another step back
to how organisms read
their genetic code to make proteins.
Recall that the order
of triplet codons in DNA
encodes the order of amino acid
building blocks in a protein.
And it's the translational
machinery of cells
that reads the triplet codons
and builds the corresponding
sequence of amino acids.
The translational machinery
of natural cells --
including ribosomes,
aminoacyl-tRNA synthetase
enzymes and tRNAs --
is a unique and special system
for making proteins
in which the 20 common amino acids
are strung together in a chain.
Now, proteins are amazing,
but they're just one example
from a vast class of molecules
known as polymers,
which includes plastics,
materials and drugs.
And the polymer or linear polymer
is really any molecule
in which simpler chemical building blocks
are strung together in a chain.
We wanted to unlock the potential
of the translational machinery
for making plastics, materials and drugs
that simply can't be made
in any other way,
or that could be made
more cleanly and efficiently
using engineered versions
of the cell's translational machinery.
The building blocks for these polymers
go well beyond the 20 common amino acids
used to make proteins.
It's been impossible
to unlock the potential
of the translational machinery
for making plastics, materials and drugs
for two reasons.
First, all 64 triplet codons
in natural cells
are used for making natural proteins,
and there are simply no codons available
to encode the synthesis of new polymers.
Second, the natural
translational machinery
specifically uses natural amino acids
and simply can't use
the chemical building blocks
required to make new polymers.
However, a virus-resistant organism
doesn't use all 64 triplet codons
to make proteins
and doesn't contain the machinery
to read the codons
that have been deleted from its genome.
And this cell provides the starting point
for genetically-encoded polymer synthesis.
To realize genetically-encoded
polymer synthesis
in our virus-resistant organism,
we added synthetic DNA
containing the triplet codons
we'd removed from the genome of the cell
and engineered translational machinery
to read these codons
and reassign them to new chemical
building blocks for new polymers.
This system can be programmed
to make diverse synthetic polymers.
By changing the order
of the triplet codons
in the synthetic DNA,
we can change the order
of the chemical building blocks
that we program
into the resulting polymer.
And by changing the identity
of the engineered translational machinery
that we add to the cell,
we can change the identity
of the chemical building blocks
from which we compose the polymer.
Overall, we've created a cellular factory
that we can reliably
and predictably program
to make synthetic polymers.
Using our approach,
we've already been able to program cells
to make new molecules,
including molecules
from an important class of drugs
known as depsipeptide macrocycles.
Molecules in this class
include antibiotics,
immunosuppressives
and anti-tumor compounds.
We've also been able to program cells
to make completely synthetic polymers
containing the chemical linkages found
in several classes
of biodegradable plastics.
As we build new polymer molecules
using our cellular factories,
we have the opportunity
to consider from the beginning
how we might also use
engineered biological cells
to break these polymers down
into their constituent
chemical building blocks
that could be recycled
and used for new encoded polymers.
We envision a circular bioeconomy
in which our new genetically-encoded
plastics and materials
are manufactured
and ultimately broken down
using low-energy cellular processes,
taking advantage of existing
bioreactors and fermenters.
By taking inspiration from nature
and reimagining what life can become,
we have the opportunity to build
the sustainable industries of the future.
Thank you.
(Applause)